ce matin le ministre de l'éducation
monsieur françois bayrou tenait une
conférence de presse au printemps
dernier il avait annoncé sa volonté de
faire en sorte que l'école soit à
nouveau un sanctuaire de tranquillité et
d'éducation il a répété ce matin d'une
certaine façon en appelant les parents à
apprendre à leurs enfants le respect de
l'école et des enseignants
françoise david christian leroux les
policiers en faction devant un collège
c'était l'hiver dernier la violence
avait fait irruption dans certains
établissements de banlieue agressions
physiques et verbales contre les
professeurs déprédations des locaux
scolaires et du matériel intrusion
d'éléments étrangers à l'école la
violence dans les établissements
scolaires faisait la une des journaux
neuf mois après le ministre de
l'éducation nationale s'adresse aux
parents et il me semble qu'il est donc
normal de faire en cette rentrée un
appel pour que les français soutiennent
davantage les enseignants qu'ils les
respectent qu'ils transmettent ce
respect à leurs enfants
c'est important pour l'école mais c'est
très important pour eux évoqué les
orientations pour protéger l'école de la
violence le gouvernement a décidé une
série de mesures création d'une
contravention pour intrusion doublement
du nombre d appeler présent dans les
collèges meilleure formation des
professeurs des établissements sensibles
certains enseignants restent sceptiques
ça peut contribuer à améliorer climat
dans les établissements mais
fondamentalement ce qu'il faut faire
c'est permettre aux enseignants de
d'approché de façon plus individualisé
les jeunes qui ont de gros problèmes à
l'extérieur de l'école et à l'intérieur
de ne pouvons pas le faire dans des
classes à 27 28
les syndicats enseignants restent donc
mobilisés pour obtenir des postes et des
moyens supplémentaires